hey folks and welcome back to another
week of top five Skyrim mods I'm cam and
this is SAP or top 5 scary mods of what
cam the month I mean say I did say this
week at the beginning implying a weekly
show it's okay you guys know you guys I
was right B you know it is another
episode of top 5 square miles of the
weakness we have I'm gonna do the
straightaway do it we have sense to be
recall to save we got sent a new
wallpaper by master designer Smith okay
Sonny who is done loads of cool stuff
prosper smithing would be at a hundred
that's for sure
it in lieu of the debaters is you said
Smith over this chicken yeah I got you
got it okay sorry continue let's let's
hurry up again today in lieu of the
chicken debate he has made us this
awesome poster and it looks fantastic
and I think we need to put it on the
tumblr blog oh definitely yeah yeah
absolutely it's basically I mean just
look at it it's glorious
it's absolutely glorious I do I love I
love what I've always done with the
lighting to make it fit into the scene
and the fact the chicken is looking back
at we assume is Kevin yeah in the you
know the standard salad iron armor oh
there's like [__] it's great amazing
of it all that dragon chicken overhaul
mods I don't think there are don't there
is one I've never seen why find it find
it if there is one
find it if there's not one make it yeah
but that's order yes Karen definitely do
that for us we're gonna do a slightly
different format show today that's true
we are and so one of the things that
kind of annoys us about making the show
sometimes as we get group recommended so
many amazing quest mods yeah I can't
ever properly dig into them but just
only got so much time to make it we
wanted like showcase 5 mods because in
the name of the show but this week
screwed numbers we say we're gonna
basically do we do say that 1 mod well
we're actually gonna do two because it
still the user fees of any mod that's
like the bonus we're gonna do one main
mod but don't worry it's gonna be at
least four times as good
I know times as long four times as long
so it's gonna it's gonna be at the same
feel
but just one quest mod so sab let's get
straight to it
zebb were back in scarm it's Kevin Van
Nord but yes guy room looks a little
different last time we play only a
little differently have a trained eye
don't explain what's been going on but
over the scenes I would have learnt a
week I would love to while you run
around hopefully finding a courier who
might be after okay this is so what's
happened basically is people who've been
following the show may know that not too
long ago we completely rebuilt our
Skyrim machine yes we did a whole video
of us physically put pieces in I was
varible you were awful I was really bad
one of the bugs that we've been having
with it though was to do with the
motherboard and basically we stuff what
was happening was that often when the
computer was idling you just turn off
its turn oh yeah so what we had mark do
mark the PC building genius wizard is we
had him a biasing new full-size board by
my crazy ex 1 oh look at this guy
running right at you I wouldn't kill him
if we need him right fine
uh let's find out what he's saying first
your hands oh really
let's see looks like that's it we've got
to go thanks curry man thanks friends
nice hahaha oh that this case us to a
thing that people been asking is why do
we not have the mod on that allows us to
kill everyone um we really should put
that mod on every week Wow look at this
goal the problem with having the mod on
that lets everyone be killable is that
you technically slowly but surely break
Skyrim yeah I guess so in my mind I
would rather I'd rather have Lydia fight
him for all eternity yeah okay then
sorry back to the PC so what have we got
under the desk now so now it's all the
same bits with the exception of the
motherboard which is an MSI gaming
motherboard and a full-size case as well
because we've gone from lightest micro
ATX form factor to a full-size cool
factor so everything else is same same
graphics card same processor seals 16
gigs of ram all that good stuff it has
better air flow if you care
iCare iCare bloody also but the reason
why
garam looks slightly different the last
time we played is because some of the
bytes that we were using actually are no
longer on the Nexus you can't get him so
lush trees and grass for example trees
and grass we hardly knew you so I've
installed replacement mods for all of
these things and some of them are
working well some of them less well
we're gonna kind of pick away at it as
we go on and add and remove stuff you
know what I can lose pretty great it
look it does I think it looks pretty I
think it runs quite well and this spot
here is a perfect spot just like chilla
and read read a little note that's me
today let's do it aha I hope this letter
finds you well for Skyrim morrowind and
the great house how hello Allah o our
Allah need your strength
well of course everyone's any guest
right I crave threat for my homeland of
more wind is migrated to Skyrim and no I
nip at its heels I feel like I cannot
bring it down alone please if you care
at all for this land and her peoples
people some people yeah meet me at the
sleeping giant in your river would as
soon as you can oh wow Gabe I was just
hours I remember when the tree choice I
should have read the letter first yep
this one will do I do love the sleeping
giant in you know the fire big candles
and orange candy body to just Deadspin
heads back oh yeah it's for maybe we
could have roast Deadspin right we need
to meet someone here I wish you nice
knots fan I hope not
otherwise we've already done did oh this
guy hello man Dane lalu we'll call you
Manny
hey Manny I should get going there I'd
leave you sent for me so I did
Dragonborn
hmm boys I think yes this is so much
power
yes and there's no Kevin ban or looking
at you what sorry to business as
neighbors Skyrim and morrowind share
more than a border or fates are
intertwined mmm girl for one another
look he can't drink men talk and a
famous criminal from morrowind was
spotted in sky I was dispatched by house
flower to find him however he is too
deadly for me to face me because you're
weak he rose him this hero comes with a
fee the fee this hero shelter that's
great he's a thousand Septimus be too
dangerous
yeah thousand more I'm a really really
good here hahaha the high glow as well
mm scepter yes I have to offer excellent
okay we get alright we have a deal I
tracked the criminal to a village
southwest of here called little Vivek
but after that trail went cold because
you didn't go to Lulu Vick you may have
me out luck not only is he a fearsome
combatant but he is silver tongued if he
begs for his life do not believe a word
he says
hmm interesting I better get started
before you go what take this ring okay
the criminal is known to wield enchanted
blades and this may protect you for
protection happy hunting Dragonborn
right many thanks you are doing both
Morrowind and Skyrim a great service all
right where we going I guess little
Vivek I see it I got a little Vivek is
that a taro that's where to pop into
existence yes there it is and a boat
thank God that boat is there little
Vivek discovered so we didn't even see
what the name of this quest is alright
yeah we didn't even say that so this mod
is called moon and star moon and star it
actually came recommended and it is by
Gann zing Dolph go yes Dan Gandalf of
course I can zing bah
let's go talk to her well hello there hi
I do for you today
has anyone passed through the village
whoa whoa oh yeah oh of course we could
visitors every now and then you should
ask my husband if you're looking for
someone he just adores talking to
visitors
alright I wonder where her husband is
hello ah this guy what's this a new
visitor
I really hope part of this quest is
killing this guy I hope so
why's she married to him well so what
one gentleman who passed through he wore
armor made in Morrowind learn about her
beautiful glades he sounds like the
Simpsons guy I had a smoothie hey is
this chat your go down lie son
travelling just ever pick the lock of
his chest yeah and there's a journal in
here and steal all his possessions an
inheritance
let's read it in front of him something
not from you anymore cuz I already have
all your stuff thanks about ladies let's
just eat ice start a journal she says
that I speak little yeah the Yeti area
visitor keen to village a man I knew
open ever met write his name such this
caliber his name was Kevin van Nora yes
so talking about Dwemer ruin hmm Karen
Karen are this is like the man I'm after
so off to Cochran are we go oh I'm good
idea let's use these steps Nanna that's
that's ridiculous
ha how do we miss this amazing enormous
city I need to make it bigger
here we are sab CAG Rinna oh is that a
guy that person dad's spiders and
spheres lots of dead things
what are you the heart of kagrenac I
guess we end this now yeah I'll take
that I think that it's good to take
things
it's good to just Rob in general so
presumably now that we have the heart of
this place we're looking for the chest
of this place I guess the first question
free now read that book has but a single
page and there's a text in the ancient
Dwemer you cannot read it but someone
has scrawled a rough translation it's
powerful magic given form seven to Souls
it binds with an ancient force that's
the question okay when the answer is
empty you think we put things in the
chest yes that's exactly what I'm
thinking
I think it's put two things I'm holding
in the chest yeah well you were wrong
sab oh man well oh oh crap we go Smee
killing today this is much slower than
punching
pretty good no does that mean this to
all the doors open yep just like that I
thought was awesome
to the depths obviously and I see uh I
hear I hear some something for us to
fight there he is is this our man no man
look at that can we can we talk
somewhere a little quieter please you
light in here suffice it to say that
weapon lies dormant perfect so I'm gonna
go find it it is you I'll be sent to
destroy he has a silver tongue do not
trust him that's true
I hope why
Wanda stammering helping those someone
wants him dead
hmm um was a mistake well looks like
we're up for a fight this guy's pretty
Hardy yeah however your name is Wow
uh-oh no head for you ha ha ha
turns out he wasn't immortal oh man all
right yeah I guess things are our source
this is great thanks friends oh that
looks like a big Centurion thing it does
look like a big Centurion thing oh I
wonder if he's uh item if he's gonna
help us I can breathe it you two friends
so is this the weapon too powerful oh
man this guy's hardcore he just heals
himself because of all the energy so we
need to be activating the energy all
right ow ah okay you can't just stand in
the way of it that's good to know so
that did something well that looks red
now that one's red
maybe now you can attack whatever that
is yes yes you get it alright so now we
got to do the red one so I do make
someone else red there you go the hammer
the hammer we're on to this herb we are
totally totally doing this yeah
blank blank got it
yes yes let's use a hope hopesfire and
trueflame it's what he would have wanted
that's using weapons we stole from other
people yeah giant mechanical man ah the
cars weak you okay cake all right so I
think we finished everything we can from
here we've killed the guy we were sent
to kill whether I have we were actually
meant to that you know Kevin kills
everybody so Kevin is always gonna take
the option where somebody dies exactly
oh look who it is ah there you are I was
beginning to worry you wouldn't be
leaving that place at all now if you
would be so kind could you return that
ring I let you its payment for not
telling retiree it was not that in my
defense I did not lie it was a criminal
before he was the nerevarine he arrived
on the shores of Aden fell in Chains you
know with names and titles matter little
now just return the ring I won't ask
again
I don't think so pity whatever lay in
those ruins seems to have taken its toll
on your mind as well as your body for
the Dragonborn to die in such a state
tragic bring it oh he might be okay
still Wow there we go that was it
and it ended as it began with death
everywhere I want to hear I want to read
the honorable writ of execution we need
to read that the aforementioned
personnage has been marked for honorable
execution in accordance to the lawful
tradition and practice of the morag tong
guild whilst ever said this that's that
quest done yeah I know it was really
great it started with with some death
the courier daddy with some deaths and
there was a death in the middle whole
lot of death which you know Kevin he
likes that I mean honey got a spiffing
you gone I think it's free gloves look
at that
damn it's time for the user voted mod of
today which is mod 2 more than really
and we're here at Whiterun stables yes
and what's new in this mod sir
so the one that one is the one that one
is Ghost Rider transformation which I
can be honest surprised me yeah but you
you guys wanted to see it so we're gonna
see it we're going to break into the
stables can definitely do novice whoop
oh dear
Oh God that's fun huh we got it yeah
that we got a piece of cake now look to
your left her friend and get a moment to
herself know how it's still stealing
from the hell chest do you really want
to do this oh no oh no Kevin you da I
don't think her neck is hurt oh that's
us jobs one nothing happened in there no
let's don't go in there yeah nobody was
hurt ah
alright so it's the the hell thingy so
it's a book of spells on Ghost Rider of
vengeance learn I think that's it
alright magic so it's over in powers to
the far right back one there you go and
you want to be in third person for this
third person alright here we go you
ready sad I am definitely ready
oh consumed by flames be going well for
Kevin that so far no
and here's our man that's kind of
awesome
yeah great work a fiery skill man we are
and I think we will stay on fire for the
duration of being fiery skull man now
there's an issue with one of the spells
on the right trigger seems to crush the
game it does so I'm not gonna use that
now use the left trigger so when you are
in the form of Ghost Rider there you go
you got your little crossbow now whoa
and you can fire fireballs oh this guy
works that works so the one drawback of
doing a Ghost Rider man is that you have
no ability as far as I can tell to equip
your own stuff but you can blow people
up well so we see how skull man flies
let's see how skull man flies all right
so be ready phantom bolt I think I just
hit a chicken with it I'm gonna do that
but lick the fire amazingly is
unaffected yeah because you would have
soared at that altitude the lower oxygen
level might even play flames I want to
do a thing okay I've got a plan
so let's put a whole load chickens over
here I see I've got much better idea
mm-hmm put a whole lot of chickens over
here by the giant oh yeah hey we brought
you some dinner chickens run a little
bit away run away run away run away
launch that time I think you also got
the garden Oh sir and I did yeah
bigger that's very Oh I was very good I
like most to reload it as he started to
fire in the air yeah he never knows when
he might need another fireball oh yeah
you know but a good flight nonetheless
mm-hmm
I'm not gonna lie that mod was better
than I was expecting
yes agreed agreed awesome we'll say
bless give us some of the comments and
questions we have for this week I would
love to the first one comes from cress a
knight
it does and it says do you guys get the
same CBS interactive features like
payday drinks and waffle Wednesday's yes
we do how how did you know I don't know
a general Bert waffle wing I don't know
who this mystery insider is waffle
Wednesday's is a thing instigated by the
lovely folks at last.fm yes they joined
us in this office but two years ago yeah
and before then there was no waffle
Wednesday and then this the thing they'd
been doing for years and they make
waffles I'm not gonna lie not every
Wednesday is like one Wednesday a month
waffle Wednesday is delicious there will
say whoever you are mystery and slider
do you know reveal yourself as you are
through the Skyrim handshake mm-hmm but
we all know your mouth so the next one
can silver I says really bugs me that
there's so much clipping issues with the
shields I agree
they look great maybe it's just the
armored doing it the clipping just takes
away from it unfortunately yeah it could
be fixed so that's a reference to one of
the mods we had last week yeah which was
do you remember so much I can find it
something to do with shield it was the
Forgotten weapons of art yes that was it
and the shields were fantastic but yeah
they did clip by badly which get was a
shame yeah I mean there there are other
mods that fix clipping issues like that
you know like animation mods that that
have you hold stuff in bone array yeah
there are tons of ones it's probably a
thing that you just can I have to kind
of live with probably for the most part
but it's more just appreciating the
design yeah if you want a big shield
clipping as well as things you have to
deal with oh yeah all right said the
next question you want to take this is
from Theo Noble all right Cavan said
yeah hi I have one or two questions for
you which one is it first off I'm
guessing to hash tag old chicken awesome
right we need to come back to hash tag
or chicken in a minute oh we will
secondly I'm trying to get a good strong
computer for modding cheaply because I'm
a console user which sucks got any ideas
short and sweet do a modded let's play
with the essential mod bids and extras
for fun it would be very cool and
finally I'm too
Hung's go to a bar 17 so if you guys
could have a little balloon that says
Theo one very happy thanks for the
awesome content and thanks for hopefully
reading well face for the comment Theo
okay so a few things here yeah we'll
come back to hash tag or chicken in a
minute but I'm so happy like a good
strong modding PC even not too much
money yeah well you can bill I mean you
don't need something crazy strong to get
the basics cameras running the only
things that are really demanding I like
texture packs which have really high
resolution textures are very very EMBs
yeah which are the lighting not but and
with a pretty low-rent PC you can do
everything else yeah modding wise I
would say you could aim for maybe like
our old rig for example our old rig was
an Intel i5 8 gigs of ram and for the
most part we were running a gtx 680
which i think he could pick up for like
a hundred and fifty pounds now yeah and
it the whole thing was built pretty
cheaply and it ran Skyrim with mods with
texture packs with the mb/s fairly well
for the longest alright it was fine so
that would probably be my suggestion
basically and finally says I'm too young
to go to the bar 17 well we actually had
a tweet from the loading bar yeah you're
able to go into the loading bar before 9
o'clock
obviously not purchase drinks yeah if
you're over if you're between 16 and 18
yeah went into the bar before 9 o'clock
yeah unfortunately though our event is
still 18 plus because of what we're
showing and just the nature of the event
it's an 18 plus event I'm afraid so
there but that was a little
technicalities yeah I feel like you got
your hopes up and then - them I'm sorry
you did if you said it's a believe on
them up
I - them you said this yeah that was it
if you send us a balloon with Theo on it
we will absolutely blow it up and have
it in the background yes and finally
said let's go to a wonderful tweet from
Courtney Finney she said I really said
we go at conference Rob you guys will
appreciate this yeah this was our
wedding cake ok oh look at it it is
alright so first of all you've got the
the word wall at the top obviously which
is just fantastic then you've got the
the wilds of Skyrim I guess in the
middle and it's bottom you've got the
well what was it was it um Ottomans wall
yes where you go with Esbern to look at
the wall that the wall in the trailer
yeah when he's like they should have
acted they're already here yes that one
is it's fantastic and good I'm pretty
pleased in my response to this sab which
was a I fish roe do which I thought was
pretty good I first row do so which it
would you have to say that during the
ceremony like yeah I'd be like do you
take this one take Evan fine your
wife-to-be your you be like I first do
lose but push them across the well I see
them through the wall yeah perfect
my love again what is this always happen
because you always safe most robust yes
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm so sorry
oh it's just I swear I will never push
or do it again oh god damn it be
wonderful yes anyway that was a great
tweet thank you much for sending it and
thank you for all of your questions and
comments Yan said that means it brings
us to the vote for next week yeah now we
have three months as always mm-hmm the
first one you can vote for is shadow ran
yeah it came second last week yes yes so
it's a weapon somebody had written a
comment saying there's some law behind
shadow right so if it wins then we can
we continue feel the lore yeah next one
is the deer of a keen race yeah as it
sounds it's gonna be as good as itself
oh but this one is the one that I really
want to win there's sweet roll
randomization lat oh it changes
everything you know about this placement
and use of sweet rolls on INSCOM sounds
bad I think I think it sounds great I
think it sounds incredible actual easing
yeah
alrighty and then there are three really
good mod they are all good choice I'm
just gonna keep it in them up for the
work really well Billy on time for the
choose-your-own-adventure yes they said
once again it seems like I'm now the
author of choose-your-own-adventure
Potter
yeah well you know joying it given that
I do everything else so it's fair that
you do one thing there fair enough yeah
um so last week I'll set up and you can
read out okay but last week at Kevin was
in the bar if you remember I didn't he
trotted on poor fluffy he had and the
stranger was a very sad and Kevin
I read that there's only one thing he
could really do about it sure and his
options were kill the man and send him
to see his pet in the afterlife yes one
he didn't know I never plan on dying
sure
I'm summer - was killing his friends to
distract him from the pain of his lost
pet a reasonable response third was hand
the man the ski trip a saying down and
UK and Fluffy's on her show - what which
was the one I thought was gonna win and
then finally just simply burn the place
to the ground
yeah and the winning one I want to show
you by how much at one edge okay this
this is gonna be really impressive yeah
do I know the link I do because he knows
that I have for his blog if we go to the
camp res blog and we we go to the I like
the one I titled skiver pate O'Shea I
get the results and we can see that burn
the place to the ground one with 48% of
the vote that is powerful that's a
powerful vote average the one I want I
was thought would win was second with
26% kill a man's friends know this oh
yes story I know what I wanted actually
killing my friends was second hand the
man the spirit party was third with only
18% and kill a man to see his pet in the
afterlife
I see so I burn place the ground it was
down there do you wanted to want to take
it away I would love to take it away cuz
I actually I thought Kevin was gonna
hand him the Skiba pate and like spread
a bit on toast yeah yeah it could happen
to listen delicious alright so Kevin
decided there was only one rightful
course of action he must burn the place
to the ground all it took was one swipe
of his hand across his cheek and sparks
flew from his diamond tips stubble then
using solely the power of his cheeks he
blasted the floor and walls of the pub
with super strength
ale dear and at once the place was
ablaze using the stranger as a fire
shield he safely exited the pub as the
rest of the customers fled to safety
amazingly the stranger still clung to
life despite the tremendous burning dear
coughing and sputtering he looked up at
Kevin with eyes that said you almost
killed me Kevin's eyes replied I'm not
done yet
and with that he held the stranger
upwards with a force never seen before
or since in Skyrim the sonic boom shook
trees and echoed across all of soul
steamers he broke the sound barrier
the half-charred man soon became a
half-charred astronaut as he left the
confines of nerds atmosphere in the
direction of the Sun Kevin felt hungry
throwing enemies into the Sun gave him a
mighty appetite his stomach rumbled
causing the smoldering ruins of the pub
to fall to the ground with that he
opened his sack and browsed the
ingredients only one item would properly
suppress his appetite licking his lips
he reached in and grabbed hmm and it's
up to you neither grabs a sweet roll
delicious one steals ordered the blaze
delicious a hundred nine roots less
delicious but noisy no yes or some
dragon but very delicious some dragon
boats oh yeah so it's up to you guys
sweet roll a steel sort of the braze I'm
a bad habit they're a steel sword of the
boys extra delicious right there are
some dragon bones hmm as always it's up
to you go to tinyurl.com /cam frass blog
yes you read again and cast your votes
I'm Lokhande next week we will continue
that wasn't see what Kevin eats that was
quite the story that was scrapped like
that was a short one but I feels pretty
long but that might be the longest one
yet and I mean honestly like you really
kind of went to town on that I did my my
little scripts are much shorter for the
for the vote for the odd folk I want
which are we eternal gave the link to
before what time you probably already
know the mod for Windham on tomorrow is
tinyurl.com /r Eddie SEBI blog yes just
there so that's the two blogs you need
obviously all you need in your life if
you're watching and watching you can
press blog I I add it to the description
so you can clip the two blog links there
plus plus the tumblr link as well
because the tumblr is where we're going
to put some of these pictures especially
that picture that we showed off at the
beginning of the episode I will always
forget what the tiny URL link is to the
blog but you can just google The
Adventures of Kevin Van Doran and you
will find it or kevin vanden or tumblr
calm there it is obviously that's really
easy that's why I forget is extremely
having fun is what it is okay
yep
is so wonderful that leads us to I guess
kind of the end of the show I guess an
update on ticket sales yeah let's do it
yes skyrim live Skyrim love star life
which is a real thing and happening next
weekend March 7th of March is a Saturday
so close I'm gonna be it's gonna be it's
gonna be the best I'm gonna find out how
many tickets right this way miss moment
have been so a moment that you're
watching okay I tell you it's not sold
out yet okay close 85 out of 121 right
so they'll some up for grabs
85 85 people at a minimum are gonna be
there yep to watch it live which is kind
of crazy but if you have not got your
ticket like yet it's not too late no go
get it goodbye okay so by a URL is
tinyurl.com /gs Skyrim Life feel like we
must make tinyurl.com a lot of money we
should start our own one you know like
cuz games what does have a bitly thing
but you know it would be gamespot.com
4/6 3 to 7 could name them you've never
met yeah which which is it's just easier
this way as good as yeah all of the
links should be in the description if
the description has been updated I know
sometimes it doesn't get updated until
Monday but you know that shouldn't
happen yeah yeah okay so guys thanks
very much for watching as always I can't
wait to do the live episode yes you guys
but but we have one more episode of
Skyrim mods to go alive before then we
do yes although if you watch this on
youtube the next week's episode will
also land on the day of the lower lips
it will be it will be happening it'll go
live as we're recording this oh that's
exciting
yeah really exciting so you know if you
are watching us live please don't pull
out your phones and just like start
watching last week's episode cuz that'll
hurt what really it's still watching us
okay that's fine that's fine I said okay
guys well we will be back next week
probably with a full complement of five
months do Oya don't forget to let us
know how you what you thought of our
kind of different show this week yeah
the one main mod we'd love to hear your
thoughts
but with that next week more Cameron
said more kevin vanden more Skyrim mods
see it
you